alors je pense que vous entendez aussi
bien qu un bond de ses applaudissements
qui dure depuis un certain temps notre
les spectateurs se pose peut-être la
question seulement être pour toi tu sais
que mes collègues de la salle du nouvel
an d'actionnement en âge d'aller
souligné mais sony qui est toujours non
non non ce parent directeur général de
l'information de radio-canada mais qui
quittera ses fonctions au cours des
prochains jours allaient en haïti est
formé aujourd'hui même il c'est de me
dire que ça a été un choc que pour la
très grande majorité de mes collègues du
métier parmi eux bien sûr c'était
quelqu'un qui était vraiment très
apprécié au service de nouvelles
pratiques al adha journaliste de
formation réalisateur il m'a fait
beaucoup pour le service de
l'information de radio-canada c'est à
lui que l'on doit notamment
l'intégration des différentes
plateformes ces risques l'île de ré du
canada d'ici dit dans son ensemble c'est
en bonne partie grâce à lui que mes
collègues de la télévision de la radio
du web global ensemble maintenant alors
c'est évidemment une nouvelle qui nous a
tous un peu bouleversé une nouvelle avec
laquelle il faudra apprendre à composer
surtout dans un contexte qui s'annonce
assez difficile de reconnaître pour est
au canada dans la mesure où le
gouvernement conservateur de stephen
harper demande un peu à tous de faire un
effort budgétaire
dans la mesure où ils demandent aux
différentes ce qui est des fans de rugby
dans leur budget à 5-6 peut-être même
10% dans certains cas alors ça dure
comme ça depuis des minutes et des
minutes allait s'ennuyer dès qu'il en
aurait bien aimé discuter pendant
quelques instants défi compte tenu de
l'émotion qui l'assaillent probablement
actuellement préfère s'abstenir alors
votre vote lui c'est tout le monde
parenthèse je pense que ça c'est un
concept inconnu du sarthon sens bon on
va tenter de retourner à bout vous aviez
quelque chose à rajouter joué mais j'ai
joué ma droite à ses collègues devant
mais je suis certaine que les collègues
des autres qu'ils ont également ont le
même sentiment le sentiment est partagé
dans toutes les régions du canada
absolument pour rien